One of the things I've discussed with you guys
a bunch over the last four years and really over
the last two months in particular, are a lot of
these right wingers are a lost cause. And they
voted for Trump once or twice, whatever. You know,
they may never understand the error of their ways,
but that it's important for us to remember
that there were lots of supposed left wingers
who back in 2016 maybe stayed home because
they didn't think it was important enough.
The difference between Trump and Hillary. And they
said, I'm going to stay home if it's these two,
I'm kind of opting out. Some leftists said I
almost would rather it be Trump if it's not going
to be my preferred candidate because Hillary is
just a centrist shill and they would be the same.
And of course, we found out that that's
very much not the case. We have seen
Donald Trump do things that I never imagined any
president would do. Never mind Hillary Clinton.
I have not been calling for apologies, but I have
been saying it would be important to recognize how
wrong those leftists were. I did get a
call from someone this morning saying,
I regret not voting for Hillary in 2016. It
was wrong of me not to do that. Take a listen.
A day from holding my baby, so you hear a little
talk that might be him, but I just want to call
you and say I was watching the show on the 11th
and I am one of the people who did not vote for
Hillary in 2016. Right. I voted for Jill and
I regret that since then I voted for Joe this
election cycle because people like you and Destiny
who taught me about harm reduction. Wow. And I am
eternally grateful for that. So thank you for
teaching me about harm reduction. But that was
really, really good for my life and really
probably good for the country. Thanks anyway.
So that's a beautiful voicemail and
it's great to hear things like that.
And we also need to recognize that in order to
really get more change, we have to deprogram
some of the 75 million trumpets that sure, you
know, we learned something like what was it? Eight
percent of Bernie's supporters ended up voting
for Trump instead of Hillary in 2016. These are
relatively small numbers. They could have made a
difference, by the way, because it was so close
in 2016. But we really need to attack the issue
of the 75 million people who thought voting for
Trump after four years of disaster was was a good
idea or at least a better idea than voting for
Joe Biden. On today's bonus show, Congresswoman
Liz Cheney facing major blowback after embracing
the impeachment of Donald Trump in the House.
We will talk about the metal detector, guns on
the House floor fiasco that is plaguing the House
of Representatives. And Michigan Governor Snyder
has been criminally charged. Rick Snyder
criminally charged in the Flint water crisis.
We will talk about the charges. He's up against
the possible penalty and what we expect.
Flint still has a water problem. Understand how
long it's been. Flint still has a water problem.
All of those stories and
more on today's bonus show.
You can get instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at Join Pakman Dotcom. It's quick. It's
easy. You can use the coupon code better. Twenty
one to get yourself a discount or make a pledge at
Patreon dot com The David Pakman Show. That will
also give you access to the bonus show. In either
case, I will see you then or otherwise tomorrow.
Reminder, we are off Monday for the Martin
Luther King Day holiday off Monday, but with you
today for the bonus show and tomorrow as well.